Bad acting, worse writing, and directors put
on blast.
Some movies are so bad, even their stars hate
being in them.
Though it suffered from bad reviews upon its
initial release, "The Sound of Music" has
gone on to become one of the most beloved
movie musicals of all time.
Families regularly gather 'round their televisions
to watch it, the songs remain catchy, and
Julie Andrews' performance as Maria is an
iconic piece of work, matched only by her
role as Mary Poppins.
That said, one of the film's other stars has
never been a fan.
Christopher Plummer has spent decades reminding
viewers that he never liked "The Sound of
Music," referring to the film as "The Sound
of Mucus," "S&M" or simply "that movie" at
various points over the years.
In 2010, he told The Boston Globe:
"I was a bit bored with the character.
Although we worked hard enough to make him
interesting, it was a bit like flogging a
dead horse.
And the subject matter is not mine.
I mean, it can't appeal to every person in
the world.
It's not my cup of tea.”
Before his death in 2021, Plummer always made
his thoughts on the film clear — albeit,
while also acknowledging that people everywhere
love it.
In a 2015 interview with Vanity Fair, he said:
"As cynical as I always was about 'The Sound
of Music,' I do respect that it is a bit of
relief from all the gunfire and car chases
you see these days.
It's sort of wonderfully, old-fashionedly
universal."
By the time the film that would be released
as "Star Wars" came into his life, Sir Alec
Guinness was already a legend — and that's
why director George Lucas wanted him.
The young filmmaker hoped the name and reputation
of the star would bolster his film, which
largely starred unknowns, and offered Sir
Alec a chunk of the film's earnings in exchange.
Guinness, thinking it was just another payday,
took the job.
Then "Star Wars" became "A New Hope" and launched
the most powerful franchise in the galaxy;
a lot of people involved in the production
were happy about it, but Guinness was not.
Yes, "Star Wars" made him a lot of money,
but he famously couldn't stand the film itself.
He refused to open any mail related to the
film, and even asked George Lucas to limit
future appearances of the Obi-Wan Kenobi character
because he hated the dialogue.
"You don't need to see his identification."
"We don't need to see his identification."
"These aren't the droids you're looking for."
Most famously, Guinness once told a young
fan, who claimed to have seen "Star Wars"
many times, that he'd only sign an autograph
for him if he promised to never watch the
movie again.
Just about any list of the greatest sci-fi
films ever made has to include "Blade Runner."
Ridley Scott's 1982 classic about a cop tracking
rogue synthetic humans across a futuristic
Los Angeles is still beloved today for its
visuals, its performances, and the many mysteries
buried within its story structure.
"Blade Runner" is also remembered for overcoming
so-so reviews, extensive financial turmoil,
and development hurdles.
It's a movie that persevered, against all
odds, to become a cult classic.
"Quite an experience to live in fear, isn't
it?
That's what it is to be a slave."
While frequent re-edits, re-releases, sequels
and spinoffs have kept new audiences finding
the film and falling in love, star Harrison
Ford apparently isn't one of them.
In a 1999 interview with SFGATE, Ford said
that no matter which cut of "Blade Runner"
he watches, he responds the same way.
"I didn't like the movie one way or the other.
[...] I played a detective who did not have
any detecting to do.
In terms of how I related to the material,
I found it very difficult.
There was stuff that was going on that was
really nuts."
Despite these struggles, Ford eventually did
return to the role of Deckard for "Blade Runner 2049."
Sometimes actors dislike movies they made
because they didn't like the script, or they
just did it for the money, or they were overwhelmed
by the fame thrust upon them.
Then there's Crispin Glover, who has his own
very specific reasons for disliking "Back
to the Future."
"What are you doing, George?"
"I'm writing this down, this is good stuff."
"Yeah, okay."
In a 2012 interview with The A.V.
Club looking back on his career, Glover went
into a lot of detail about why he didn't appear
in either of the film's sequels as George
McFly.
It's complicated, and it actually helped set
legal precedent.
But according to Glover, a lot of it started
with his own dislike of the film's ending,
when Marty McFly goes back to 1985 and finds
that his parents are happy, and his father
is a successful and wealthy sci-fi author.
For Glover, that kind of ending just sends
the wrong message.
He said:
"I think there would be a better message if,
instead of the son character pumping his fist
in the air or whatever, [...] if instead the
reward was that the mother and father characters
are in love with each other.
And that there’s the potential that money
comes in.
I think [equating their new riches with moral
success] is a bad message."
For Glover, the riches as reward ending of
the film only further served corporate interests.
Director Robert Zemeckis, however, did not
seem to agree.
Kate Winslet was already an accomplished young
actor by the time "Titanic" came around, but
James Cameron's film about the sinking of
the legendary ocean liner made her into an
international superstar.
Though she's since gone on to many other roles,
and even won Oscars for her non-"Titanic"
work, Winslet will forever be known in the
eyes of many as the lovestruck Rose, immortalized
in memes and on basic cable for years to come.
That said, when the time came for a "Titanic"
3D re-release, Winslet admitted that she actually
doesn't like watching the film very much.
It's not Cameron's filmmaking, though.
It's her own performance.
She told The Telegraph:
"Every single scene, I'm like 'Really, really?
You did it like that?'
Oh my God.
[...] Even my American accent, I can't listen
to it.
It's awful.
[...] I have a hard time watching any of my
performances, but watching 'Titanic' I was
just like, 'Oh God, I want to do that again.'"
"I will never let go, Jack.
I'll never let go."
"Love Actually" is one of those films that
did well when initially released, but has
grown its audience by leaps and bounds in
the years since.
The romantic comedy anthology about various
Londoners and their relationships in the weeks
leading up to Christmas has become a holiday
staple for many, continuing to draw new fans
through annual theatrical showings and Christmas
movie marathons.
That doesn't mean everyone who worked on the
film has to like it, however.
While he acknowledges the film's impact, and
even agreed to return for the Red Nose Day
reunion special in 2017, Andrew Lincoln has
admitted in interviews that he was never too
comfortable with his own place in the film
as Mark, the lovesick man who professes undying
affection to his best friend's wife.
He told Entertainment Weekly:
"In one of the most romantic movies of all
time, I got to play the only guy who doesn't
get the girl.
The story is set up like a prism looking at
all the different qualities of love.
Mine was unrequited.
So I got to be this weird stalker guy."
In 2007, Katherine Heigl was an up-and-coming
actor still working on making the big leap
from TV stardom to movie fame.
She got a major break in the form of Judd
Apatow's "Knocked Up," a comedy about the
fallout from a one-night-stand pregnancy.
"Knocked Up" was a major success both critically
and commercially, helped make Seth Rogen into
a comedic star, and further cemented Apatow
as one of the genre's guiding lights.
For Heigl, though she enjoyed making the film,
it was also an unpleasant story about an uptight woman.
"Do not make fun of me.
Okay, I am hormonal, I am terrified, and I
am falling apart.
So stop treating everything like it's a big
joke."
She told Vanity Fair in 2016:
"It was a little sexist.
It paints the women as shrews, as humorless
and uptight, and it paints the men as lovable,
goofy, fun-loving guys.
It exaggerated the characters, and I had a
hard time with it, on some days.
[...] Ninety-eight percent of the time it
was an amazing experience, but it was hard
for me to love the movie."
Robert Pattinson was one of several young
actors who had overwhelming fame thrust upon
them, seemingly overnight, with the original
"Twilight" film.
"The Batman" brought him back to franchise
work, but Pattinson has proven himself to
be predominantly arthouse-minded.
He's not just a pretty face — he's a capable
actor.
Based on Stephenie Meyer's massively popular
novels of the same name, the five "Twilight"
films drew a rabid fanbase to Pattinson.
And while he's well aware of what the movies
did for him in terms of status, he was never
actually a fan of the movies themselves.
In 2011, he admitted to Vanity Fair that it
was "weird" to be "kind of representing something
you don't particularly like."
"You better hold on tight, spider monkey."
Asked in a Moviefone interview if he'd go
see a "Twilight" film if he wasn't in them,
he responded:
"[I] would just mindlessly hate it."
In the years since, however, he seems to have
warmed to the films.
He told USA TODAY in 2019:
"Now the intensity has died down and it's
just very warm memories."
Daniel Radcliffe's life changed forever when
he was cast as the title character in the
"Harry Potter" series of films, based on J.K.
Rowling's mega-bestseller series of books.
Radcliffe played Potter in eight different
films across an entire decade of his life,
quite literally growing up on the big screen.
The actor has fond memories of his time as
the boy wizard, and always seems happy to
share memories of making the "Potter" films.
But there is little doubt, however, which
film is his least favorite to watch.
In 2014, he told the Daily Mail:
"It's hard to watch a film like 'Harry Potter
And The Half-Blood Prince,' because I'm just
not very good in it.
I hate it.
My acting is very one-note and I can see I
got complacent and what I was trying to do
just didn't come across."
"The Help" is considered by some to be among
the best period dramas of the 2010s, and it
earned widespread acclaim.
Focusing on the interpersonal relationships
between Black women working for white people
in Jackson, Mississippi, in 1963 — at the
height of the Civil Rights Movement — it
starred Viola Davis in an Academy Award-nominated
lead role.
Today, it may be remembered as one of her
most celebrated roles, but nevertheless she's
unhappy with the film and says she was reluctant
to take the part.
She told The New York Times in 2018:
"I just felt that at the end of the day that
it wasn't the voices of the maids that were
heard.
[...] I know that if you do a movie where
the whole premise is, I want to know what
it feels like to work for white people and
to bring up children in 1963, I want to hear
how you really feel about it.
I never heard that in the course of the movie."
"Once I told the truth about that, I felt
free."
It's likely few people would know who Megan
Fox was had she not starred in Michael Bay's
"Transformers" in 2007.
The film introduced the Transformers to a
new generation, and it introduced Fox to the world.
"Why doesn't my little bunny just hop in the
backseat?"
"Oh god, I can't even tell you how much I'm
not your little bunny."
In the film, Fox plays the love interest of
Shia LaBeouf, who gets caught up in the Earthbound
adventures of Optimus Prime and crew when
they show up on their doorstep.
Since "Transformers" and its sequel brought
Fox a great deal of fame, you'd think it would
be at the top of her list of favorite projects;
that is not the case.
Fox was let go from the production of the
third "Transformers" movie, primarily due
to a falling out with Bay.
She told Wonderland in 2009 that Bay was "a
nightmare to work with," saying:
"He's like Napoleon.
[...] He wants to be like Hitler on his sets,
and he is.
So he's a nightmare to work for."
Following something of a public feud, Fox
and Bay reconciled, even working together
in the rebooted "Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles"
films.
Looking back on "Transformers" and its sequel,
Fox has said she hates her acting.
She told Entertainment Weekly in 2009:
"People are well aware that this is not a
movie about acting.
Once you realize that, it becomes almost fun
because you can be in the moment and go, 'All
right, I know that when he calls 'Action!'
I'm either going to be running or screaming,
or both.'"
Ryan Reynolds has starred in several high-profile
superhero movies, but he only truly regrets
one: "Green Lantern."
Intended to launch a franchise of DC Comics
films, Reynolds was at the center of it all,
and anticipation was high while the film was
in production.
Cast as Hal Jordan, the cocky test pilot who
stumbles upon an alien that bestows upon him
a Green Lantern power ring, the film had all
the right names and story beats of the comics.
But all the anticipation landed with a thud,
collapsing in a brightly-lit CGI mess that
didn't even include a real suit; the movie
did so poorly at the box-office that it upended
DC's plans at the time.
In the years since, Reynolds has not been
shy at joining in on the joke.
The actor has mocked his performance and various
aspects of the film on multiple occasions.
"And please don't make the super suit green.
Or animated."
Reynolds doubled down in "Deadpool 2" by going
back in time and shooting himself in the head
just as he's about to accept the role of Hal
Jordan.
He's gone on talk shows, appeared in commercials,
and tweeted endlessly about the full scope
of "Green Lantern's" awfulness.
Reynolds told Entertainment Weekly in 2016:
"It also fell victim to the process in Hollywood,
which is like poster first, release date second,
script last."
"Grease" was a massive hit that turbo-charged
the careers of Olivia Newton-John, John Travolta,
and others.
The film's sequel was an often forgettable
pile of celluloid — except for the fact
that it gave the world one Michelle Pfeiffer.
Marking her largest role to date at the time,
"Grease 2" revisited Rydell High School some
two years after the previous film, this time
depicting British student Michael and the
object of his affections, Stephanie, the leader
of a girl's gang that only allows its members
to date greasers... for reasons.
"Grease 2" gave Pfeiffer a chance to show
her stuff, singing and dancing and taking
a big leap towards becoming a household name.
But it is also regarded by some to be among
the worst musicals of all time.
She told Hollywood.com in 2014:
"I hated that film with a vengeance and could
not believe how bad it is.
At the time, I was young and didn't know better."
Pfeiffer also didn't think she'd get the part,
calling her casting a "total fluke."
"High School Musical" was a massive success,
and it launched the career of multiple stars,
including Zac Efron.
Not only was the film a hit, but it also spawned
two sequels, and Efron starred in both of
them, playing Troy Bolton to widespread popularity.
Efron was a teenage heartthrob who could sing,
dance, and look good doing it.
"Whoa.
Timeout on that one."
After he put those films in his rearview mirror,
Efron got to work playing more diverse roles.
While "Musical" made him a star, the way Efron
sees it, his most awkward stage in life was
also immortalized for generations of teens.
He discussed how the role made him feel in
a 2021 interview with Men's Journal, and said:
"I step back and look at myself, and I still
want to kick that guy's ass sometimes.
[...] He's done some kind of cool things with
some cool people, [...] but I mean, he's still
just that f---ing kid from ['High School Musical']."
By this point, Efron has done a pretty good
job leaving Troy Bolton in his past, and he's
also become a documentarian; he hosts a travel
show called "Down to Earth with Zac Efron,"
which sees him traveling the globe in search
of healthy lifestyles.
Bob Hoskins was an exceptional actor, lending
power and presence to numerous iconic roles.
But there's one iconic role that didn't work
out so well.
In fact, it's sometimes cited among the worst
movies ever made; it was also the first video
game adaptation ever put to film.
Long before Chris Pratt ever said "It's-a-me,"
Hoskins took on the role of "Mario Mario"
in "Super Mario Bros." in 1993.
His first and last name being the same in
the film was the first of many mistakes made
in its production.
With the possible exception of the costumes
for Mario and Luigi, little about the movie
relates to the source material.
"Aliens?
We gotta deal with aliens too?"
"Luigi, we're the aliens."
"We are?
Whoa, cool!"
Fans aren't the only people who hated "Super
Mario Bros."; Hoskins absolutely loathed the
film, and he never kept that disdain to himself.
He told The Guardian in 2007:
"The worst thing I ever did?
'Super Mario Brothers.'
It was a f---in' nightmare.
The whole experience was a nightmare.
It had a husband-and-wife team directing,
whose arrogance had been mistaken for talent.
After so many weeks, their own agent told
them to get off the set!"
Dismissing them as "idiots," he cited the
project as his biggest regret.
Matt Damon launched to superstardom with "Good
Will Hunting."
It brought his career to new heights, and
it helped him land his most iconic role: Jason Bourne.
Damon first played Bourne in "The Bourne Identity"
and has since appeared in three sequels.
While the movies did exceptionally well and
solidified his place as a Hollywood A-lister,
Damon isn't a huge fan of the third film,
"The Bourne Ultimatum."
In an interview with GQ, he expressed his
disappointment with the script, which he credited
to Tony Gilroy's deal to write a single draft,
take no notes or rewrites, and receive, quote,
"an exorbitant amount of money."
"You can't outrun what you did, Jason.
You made yourself into who you are."
Despite pointing out the script as the reason
for the film's lackluster performance, Damon
doesn't hold Gilroy accountable.
He explained:
"I don't blame Tony for taking a boatload
of money and handing in what he handed in.
It's just that it was unreadable.
This is a career-ender.
I mean, I could put this thing up on eBay,
and it would be game over for that dude.
It's terrible.
It's really embarrassing."
Ultimately, the shooting script was rushed
into production, due to a set release date.
Circa the late '00s, Sam Worthington had become
Hollywood's hottest flavor, landing high-profile
gigs headlining "Avatar," a "Terminator" sequel,
and a "Clash of the Titans" remake.
"Tell him.
Tell him."
"What?"
"Your journey does not end well.
Fate has spoken."
Of course, "Avatar" became a once-in-a-generation
hit, but Worthington's other two projects
didn't quite work out as well.
"Titans," which put him alongside the likes
of Liam Neeson, Ralph Fiennes, Gemma Arterton,
Mads Mikkelsen, and other celebrated actors,
did fair-to-middling business, ultimately
failing to woo critics or audiences.
The film eventually got a sequel with 2012's
"Wrath of the Titans," but Worthington isn't
a fan of his acting in "Clash."
He apologized to fans in a 2010 interview
with Moviefone, admitting:
"I think the first one, we kind of let down
some people.
I think I can act f---ing better, to be honest...
Just take all the notes from people that I
have been reading about on the 'net and give
them a movie they f---ing want."
When Brad Pitt was cast opposite Tom Cruise
in Anne Rice's eagerly-anticipated "Interview
with the Vampire" adaptation, many saw it
as a passing of the torch.
Here was Hollywood's hottest young actor matched
with its biggest star.
In this darkest of tales, who would shine
brightest?
In the eyes of some, no one.
The movie made money, but according to Pitt,
it was a nightmare to shoot.
In a 2011 interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Pitt explained how miserable he was, shooting
for six months in the dark.
On top of that, he felt his character wasn't
as fully realized as he should have been.
When asked if he knew what the role would
be going in, Pitt replied:
"No, I didn't.
There was no script.
I knew the book, and in the book, you have
this guy asking, 'Who am I?'
Which was probably applicable to me at that
time."
"You thought you could have it all."
"Oh, shut up, Louis."
Explaining that he got the script two weeks
before shooting, Pitt even tried to get out
of his contract.
He called producer David Geffen, a good friend
of his, and asked what it would cost to break
the contract.
When Geffen's answer was in the neighborhood
of $40 million, Pitt decided to take his vitriol
and, like any good vampire, just suck it up.
2015's "Terminator Genisys" cast Emilia Clarke
as a quasi-new-Linda-Hamilton in the same
character of Sarah Connor.
The film aimed to reboot the franchise once
again, and had it been successful, Clarke
would have had a cinematic vehicle for years.
"Come with me if you want to live."
Unfortunately, the movie was deemed a disappointment,
even if it did gross more than $440 million
at the worldwide box office.
Because it underperformed, the planned sequel
was scrapped.
Clarke spoke with Vanity Fair in 2018 about
her experiences filming "Genisys," noting
that she'd seen the film's director Alan Taylor
get "eaten and chewed up on 'Terminator.'"
"He was not the director I remembered.
He didn't have a good time.
No one had a good time."
On top of that, Clarke expressed relief that
she wouldn't have to make any more "Terminator" films.
According to the actor, crew on the neighboring
production of 2015’s "Fantastic Four" reboot,
another infamously troubled shoot, were spotted
wearing jackets that read "AT LEAST WE'RE
NOT ON 'TERMINATOR'."
In 2016, Clarke was asked about whether she'd
ever return to the "Terminator" franchise.
She replied:
"No.
Can I say that?
It's okay.
No.
Uh-uh."
George Clooney: Batman & Robin
If you've ever wondered what the worst "Batman"
movie was, just head into your local comic
book store, conduct a poll and you'll inevitably
hear a consensus surrounding Joel Schumacher's
last film in the franchise.
If you happen to pass by the onetime Dark
Knight himself, George Clooney, you could
ask him, and he'd likely agree.
When Clooney took the role, following Val
Kilmer in Schumacher's "Batman Forever," he
was an on-the-rise TV star navigating a tricky
transition to films.
At the time, it was the biggest thing he had
ever done, and while he recalls it as the
role that helped him secure financial freedom,
he nevertheless regrets it more than he does
being in "Return of the Killer Tomatoes."
Clooney's Batman had nipples on the bat suit,
a bat-credit card, and dialogue corny enough
to make Adam West cringe.
"Let's kick some ice."
Clooney is no fan of the movie and has apologized
to the fans several times.
During an appearance on "The Graham Norton
Show" in 2016, he remembered the experience
as a disaster.
"I always apologize for 'Batman & Robin.'"
Clooney went on to say that he thought he'd
destroyed the franchise.
"I thought at the time this was going to be
a very good career move.
Um, it wasn't."
Long before donning the Dark Knight's cowl
for the DCEU, Ben Affleck was playing a different
superhero for Marvel.
His first foray into costumed crime fighting,
however, didn't receive any encore performances.
Affleck played Matt Murdock, aka Daredevil,
in the 2003 movie, a notorious dud at the time.
While the film featured notable Easter eggs
for fans who had long hoped to see their hero
on the silver screen, it deviated from the
source enough to provoke others.
Affleck's performance isn't terrible, but
the movie features some bad acting, crummy
dialogue, and several scenes that deserve
to reside in the bottom of the discount bin
at your local 99 cent store.
In 2015, Affleck admitted to Entertainment
Weekly that the film was a misfire, saying:
"'Daredevil' didn't work, at all.
[...] That was before people realized you
could make these movies and make them well.
There was a cynical sense of 'Put a red leather
outfit on a guy, have him run around, hunt
some bad guys, and cash the check.'"